bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video sono troppo contento di
darvi questa notizia che avete letto nel
titolo perché va bene
ormai è tutto spoiler quei titoli e
proprio vero nel senso sto per
partecipare a un torneo mio primo torneo
e sport spowers sto arrivando
fall geister o di faul guys dove
parteciperanno un sacco di creators in
tutto il mondo crede sono una sola
preciso però oggi penso ai ragazzi di
dare una parte dell'eventuale vincita in
beneficenza una cosa che si usa fare
quando magari fai un torneo insomma
speriamo di raggiungere altri risultati
questo torneo avverrà il 25 luglio
quindi preparatevi segnatevi la data che
dovete guardare il pav il live perché
farò una live ovviamente durante torneo
per vedere fin dove arriviamo
nel frattempo alleniamoci sexy prayers
for connection big fans e questa notte
difficile cioè quindi c'è la befana e da
la variabile più difficile della big
fans ok ok vediamo premi non è mai
giocate la piccante ha quindi potrebbe
essere un problema
e beh non so ancora il pedale ma ci sono
dei ventilatori marsi non si non si
piegano non sembra niente di che non è
troppo difficile infatti sono lavoreremo
tutti morire come me che la gente fa
lama sta saltando e rischia di battere è
quello che ho fatto
ragazzi chi va piano va sano e va
lontano
e va a milano però funzionano così ce la
posso neanche arrivare alla fine
vabbè ma ho paura di cadere per cani non
eliminato la nona e c'è quanto visto
ecco infatti io sono stati minato perché
mi ha preso
l'uomo invisibile che sta nei nostri
cuori mia aggrappato nel vuoto terminate
deciso su questo salto lo fai a metà non
lo fai completo ok ma che ho recuperato
parecchio perché il primo arrivato
adesso pare c'è pure da saltare fist
bene fly si può anche scappare nel mezzo
ha capito che correndo tica è salita del
ritratto bravi bravi
be nice proprio loro addirittura round
dove c'è la gente non è arrivata al
traguardo
mamma mia è veramente difficile e siamo
già a quanto apre con questa è la
variante più difficile non sono molto
contento ci ha presentato l'hanno
chiamata night fever perché mai fever la
febbre del sabato sera scritto notte mai
liberty ficcata che figata
ho il presentimento che questa sciami
prendere pieno non successo sempre
quella skin che si caratterizza come
supporto
io vedo per messina dal primo perché è
una donna come ostinati quasi tutti come
ho detto ma non ho preso un impianto
vabbè io gli sto chiedendo tutti me
poiché semi check point grazie ai top
e morto mannaggia sì molto
che succede è successa una roba strana e
quindi fonti si alzano si abbassano
completamente a caso ok questo nuovo
video va bene perché la versione
difficile capire e siamo già 31 per ora
tutto onesto per ora tutto il resto non
so cosa sia io che ho perso
questa è la stagione invernale verso
perso è perso
sì sì quello delimitato da viale finale
tu non lo puoi passare pagandosi io odio
anche ray più quello dopo il ventilatore
e quello delle piattaforme non ci sono
arrivati venga eliminato spesso
instabilità ma perché mi devi gran male
mentre si corre nessuno passare in mezzo
sai che non so se passarci manco io io
ho visto che hanno scappato l'altro
skifo la
intanto precari lo stesso e fin qua
tutto bene la destra
qual è il problema il ventilatore e poi
ok ventilatore patto vediamo io non lo
posso fare questo sono garantista no che
stasera si può fare ragazzi non si può
capite che non si può fare lo sa lo ha
detto che l'ho detto prima prima di
farlo sono arrivato qua ha detto non si
può fare e vedete che non si può fare
capite quello che dicono un po
scherzando di ventilatore non si può
fare perché ti becca per forza come fai
let's go allora guardate come rimane
anche nel viola tensione è l'app che se
tra yard impero e rimane in cima a cai
mental attenzione bisognerà arrivarci
questo è presto salto a fecero quasi si
può fare un salto quello di quattro
blocchi tipo poi quando lo fai il
parkour minecraft perché non so neanche
io quando ero già tagliato un po là
ok da questa parte la tavola stato
franchi stando a risalire trova ve lo
faccio lo faccio lo faccio
era più disturbo tutto il celeste gara
per quanto grazie ma 92 faccio trovare
maledetto giallo è rimasto totalmente
intoccato no ebbene cari ci sia la cosa
migliore
male male allora son tutti quello il
celeste come perché questo sta correndo
se siamo in vantaggio però non lo so
però aver poi c'è talmente tanta roba
se volto buongiorno no secco da mi
spaventa dimmi che incoronano è stato
eliminato di chiuro è sì sì infatti sul
finale sono stati mai fatica a fare una
cosa con lantern e mondiale fidati che
saremo tutti sull'ultima piattaforma
alla fine perché la fine cosa conta è
proprio difficile quando rimanere su un
piano alto quando forti a livello
potremo fare perché la partenza
direttamente sull'ultimo piano
non corre l corry
dovresti morire perché se allora io
provo no scaduto dal blu anch'io
ora ce la giochiamo avvenendo la gente
quello mantenuto perché un matto che
corre il tuo morto come uno scemo no
come sei morto don morte come lo stupido
dai attenzione che queste giocate mentre
allora quello che correva come un matto
il dubbio che si sia auto chiude in una
zona no forse riesce ad andare col
dubbio storicamente visto che solo
ferito dovrebbe spazio dove lento e
vinto sai che devi andare dall'altra
parte opposta a togliergli la strada ed
atto gravissimo lo possiamo parlare si
torni a questa è la torneo vinto ho
vinta da questo torneo che dobbiamo fare
no giusto che i ragazzi di come si sia
piaciuto iscrivere che hai lasciato un
bel commento qua sotto su qualche
consiglio che perché prima di arrivare a
torneo video ski rischi ilare un po su
polgai se quindi tutte le migliorie che
avete scritto nel con software niente
spero che vi sia piaciuto cosi i ragazzi
delle misure al momento mi piace anche
vari social chiuso della stazione
se non solo i fischietti e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo vito e
ragazzi
[Musica]